okay
eric calder is back with us on overtime
uh this is for you why isn't biden
pushing for federal legis legalization
of marijuana
uh i think it's probably something we
ought to do given the fact that it is
something that would have a great
political benefit
and also
deals with the reality you know people
are using marijuana it's being legal
i've heard that
yeah yeah
i've heard that you've heard that you
know
um
and what's it like is it good
i only inhaled
no it's uh it's something that i think
we need to catch up drug our drug policy
needs to catch up with what the reality
is marijuana is still a schedule one
drug it's ridiculous it is ridiculous
and
republicans are going to steal the issue
i think eventually i mean something like
john boehner works for a marijuana
company now right yeah i mean it could
be one of those uh freedom issues yeah
and and of course republicans smoke lots
of pot too
um
there was not enough
[Applause]
but there was something that was passed
in the house but the republicans are
against it because they said it has too
much uh stuff about equity in there now
i understand the impetus to want to
like for example if you're going to have
new businesses that are legal in the
marijuana field yeah they probably
should go to the people who suffered the
most during the drug war right
republicans of course are saying this is
a deal breaker
what do you want half a loaf if they if
they said okay no equity is it better to
have the law passed or changed or is it
better to hold out for equity
it's better to have the law changed um
and as i said deal with the societal
reality that we have um
and you know and try to make it as
equitable as as you possibly can
but i wouldn't want to stop
the movement that i think makes sense
for the sake of for the sake of equity
okay uh panel what are your thoughts on
elon musk mandating his workers oh yes
had said the workers have to go back to
the office i love this
has this become a dated concept for
companies now yeah it's um
i'm delighted to see that because i mean
everybody knows offices where or workers
who particularly younger ones who are
saying things like they save their boss
the working from home thing it really
helps the productivity and uh if i do
have to come in could i come in like
maybe tuesdays and wednesdays
like
flip the working weeks so we have a
couple of days of work and then five
days of weekend
i think i think
i think people are on to that and um
look it is true there are some jobs that
you can do better from home but a lot of
it you know people have to get back into
the office people have to stop this
pretence they're scared to go into work
for health reasons it's [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] they're pulling a fast one
there's no reason at this stage so they
shouldn't be in the office you know
other than they don't want to be in
which case do something else okay it's
good to see people coming back to the
cities i mean we need our cities
10 20 years ago people talked about
walkable livable cities but we've let
our cities deteriorate
this was a progressive idea of livable
cities and now we've allowed them to be
turned over to open air drug scenes
homeless encampments cities are the
lifeblood of innovation of civilization
we've got to bring them back
but you know i think we really need to
ask ourselves the question it is
entirely possible that people can be
more productive at home in certain
sometimes sectors and certain sectors i
mean my law firm we do we're doing a lot
of work from home and we've had
record-breaking years the last last
couple years not spending nearly as much
on travel as we once did on the other
hand we don't mentor our young lawyers
in a way that we did and that that we
suffer in that way but it does
wind up looking elitist does it not
because the people who get true you know
yeah it's like i always thought it was
[ __ ] during the pandemic when they
were like we're all in it together no
we're not some people are at home in
their pajamas getting food delivered to
them and other people are delivering the
food yeah and that jobs that tend to be
where you can't stay home you can't you
can't be a plumber from home yeah
all the time no you got to go to where
the sink is auto construction work you
know
i always noticed that the people who had
gardens liked working from home
[Applause]
and like
like 20 somethings who were paying
thousands of dollars a month for a bed
sit and we're stuck in it right tended
to want to get back into the office you
know right fancy that okay
uh
what do you make of the herd versus
depth verdict oh okay well you brought
this up does this trial mark the end of
the metoo era no
it just marks a i think a restoration of
you know
sanity like sometimes the jury doesn't
believe somebody and we by the way you
never know you never know what goes on
in a marriage you never know what went
on between those two people i don't have
a hundred percent assurance because a
jury said johnny depp is innocent that
he's innocent i don't know but that's
the best we can do we're just humans we
try and this is the worst system except
for all the others the the only thing
that might suggest it is the end of the
mito era is do you remember the
beginning of it in 2017 2018 clearly
there was a correction that needed to
happen yes there were some powerful men
who got away with too much and bad
things for a long time and that correct
not just powerful men those are just the
ones we heard about sure there was also
ones you know yeah
but but the point is is that there was a
correction that was needed and it very
swiftly ran past the point of correction
i mean there were those things like
shitty media men there was a list people
just lost their jobs for a crowd-sourced
uh google spreadsheet right uh there
were there were you know the uh
the comic um and sorry he like he
basically got done over for a bad date
yes there was and there was there was a
period where we had these completely
deranging claims that are typical of our
era where people said things like
believe all women and really no
that's as mad as saying believe all men
right why it's right of course believe
people listen to people listen to their
arguments and their experience don't
just come out with these things so the
thing with the herd trump the herd depth
trial is interesting is the jury did
hear they did hear her contradicting her
own evidence on the stand and as mr
holden knows like juries really don't
like that they really don't like it when
they can see somebody has lied and they
could see that she'd lie like she
pretended she'd given the seven million
uh from the divorce to charity and then
it turned out that it was a
pledge she'd made she said well i think
a pledge and the donation are the same
thing you're going no
they're not
um
and so they didn't like that so so maybe
maybe it may be just after this we can
remind ourselves as you say bill like
marriages are tricky people are tricky
it's always more complex than we know
but it's certainly more complex than
these [ __ ] hashtags you know
it's more complicated than the hashtags
but let's also understand that for too
long women were not heard sure and they
need to be heard and we need to take
seriously the claims that they raise and
we should not have a presumption that
because it's coming from a woman it is
something that's made up in the same way
we all agree on that well well there's a
danger but sometimes if we think that
we've over corrected that we in fact
don't go far enough
also here's an idea if you want to try
to completely reformulate or rebrand or
reframe sexual uh etiquette between the
sexes
don't base it on hollywood
like that's true
don't do it
don't do it in a very weird industry
which actually came up with the term
casting couch right where people
actually advance for their looks for
their sexual you know wilds and much
more like start in some other business
yeah yeah
i would just said two i mean i think
we've been talking about civilization i
mean one of the differences between
civilization and not civilization is you
have a system of justice rather than a
system of revenge right the systems of
revenge are endless cycles of violence
and when you break free of that for a
justice system you're much more likely
to have that civil peace that we all
want to have all right let's go have
some right now thank you
you